i i think about this a lot
whether there'll be a time soon where we
would want to stay in video game worlds
whether it's virtual reality or just
playing video games i mean i think that
time
like came in like the 90s and it's been
that time well it's not just it's not
just games i mean it's accelerated
i just recently saw that wow and
fortnite were played 140 billion hours
and those are just video games yeah and
that's like increasing very very quickly
especially with the people
coming up now and being born now and
become you know
becoming teenagers and so on let's have
a thought experiment where it's just you
and a video game character inside a room
where you remove the simulation they
need to simulate sort of
a lot of objects if it's just you and
that character
how far do you need to simulate in terms
of zooming in
for it to be very real to you as real as
reality so like first of all you kind of
mentioned zooming in which is
fascinating because
we have these tools of science that
allow us to zoom in
quote unquote in all kinds of ways
uh in the world around us but our
cognitive abilities like our perception
system as humans
is very limited in terms of sure so we
might be very easily fooled
some of the video games like on the ps4
yeah like look pretty real to me yeah
right uh i think
you know you would really have to
interrogate i mean i think even with
what we have today
like uh i don't know ace combat seven
it's a great example right like i mean
the way that the clouds are rendered
uh it's i mean it
looks just like when you're flying you
know on a real airplane the
the kind of transparency i think that
the
you know our perception is limited
enough already
to not be able to tell some of the uh
you know some of the differences there's
a game called uh
skyrim it's an elder scrolls
role-playing game
and i just uh i played it for quite a
bit
and i think i think i played very
different than others like
there'll be long searches of time where
i would just walk around and look at
nature
in the game it's incredible oh sure it's
just like the graphics is like
wow i want to stay there it was better i
went hiking recently
it was like as good as hiking so look i
know what you mean
not to go on a huge video game you know
tangent but like
the the third like witcher game was
astonishingly beautiful right especially
like playing on
on a good hardware machine it's like
this is pretty this is pretty legit that
said
um you know i i don't resonate with the
i want to stay
here you know like one of the things
that i love to do
is to go to my like boxing gym
and in box with a guy right like that's
there's there's nothing quite like that
physical
you know experience like that's
fascinating that might be
simply an artifact of the year you were
born maybe
because if you're born today it almost
seems like stupid to go to a gym
yeah like you're going to a gym to box
with a guy why not box with mike tyson
when you
yourself is like in his prime when you
yourself are also an incredible boxer
in the video game world for me there
there's a multitude of reasons why i
don't want to box with mike tyson
right like no no no no
and i want to have an ear no but your
your skills in this
meet space in this physical realm is
very limited and takes a lot of work and
you're you're uh you're a musician uh
you're
incredible scientist you only have so
much time in the in the day
but in the video game world you can
expand your capabilities in all kinds of
dimensions
that you can never have possibly have
time in the physical world
and so that it doesn't make sense like
to to be
existing to be working your ass off in
the physical world
when you can just be super successful uh
in the video game world but i still you
enjoy sucking and stuff
yeah i i really struggling to get better
i sure do
i mean i think like these days with
music music
is a great example right we just started
you know
practicing live uh with my band again
you know after
not playing for a year and uh you know
it's just it was terrible
right we were just kind of a lot of the
nuance
you know a lot of the detail is just
that detail that takes
you know years of collective practice to
develop
uh it's just lost but it was just
an incredible amount of fun way more fun
than all the like studio
you know sitting around and playing uh
that i did you know throughout the
entire year
so i think there's something there's
something intangible
or maybe maybe tangible about being uh
being in person
i i sure hope you're wrong and that
you know we that's not something that
will get lost because i think there's
like such a large part of the human
condition
is to hang out apparently if we were
doing this
interview uh on zoom right
i mean i'd already be i'd already be
bored out of my mind
[Laughter]
exactly i mean there's something to that
i mean i'm almost playing devil's
advocate but at the same time
you know i'm sure people talk about the
same way at the beginning of the 20th
century about horses
where they're they are much more
efficient
they're much easier to maintain than
cars
it doesn't make sense to have you know
all the ways that cars break down and
there's not enough infrastructure in
terms of roads for cars
it doesn't make any sense like horses
and like nature you could do the nature
like where
you know you should be living more
natural life those are real you don't
want machines in your life they're going
to pollute your mind
and the minds of young people but then
eventually just cars took over so
in that same way it just seems uh going
back to horses
just you know well you can be you can
play uh
uh uh what is it red dead
red dead redemption redemption and uh
you can ride horses in the video game
you